aussi un phénomène d'entrisme islamiste
depuis des années pardonnez-moi mais je
crois pas être quelqu'un d'extrême j'ai
été un des premiers à le dénoncer y
compris sur les espaces balnéaires
puisque j'avais été le premier maire ce
qui m'avait été bien reposé sur les
burkinis pourquoi ça pourrait paraître
ridicule de prendre un thé à l'arrêter
mais en fait il y a une dynamique
politique de conquête de l'espace public
et de l'espace privé ça a été vraiment
une entreprise on a les choses
s'améliorent par une clarification du
droit mais c'est vrai aussi dans
l'enseignement où il y a des minorités
agissantes si on ne contre pas ces
minorites agissantes on banalise
l'islamisme radical et d'abord on trahi
l'esprit républicain universaliste on ne
respecte pas la civilisation française
mais en plus on laisse nos compatriotes
musulmans les les plus intégrées ceux
qui sont français et qui le sont de
façon pleine et entière finalement se
voir marginaliser au sein des pratiques
en